Welcome to the first mini project.
It's on the topic of Naive Bayes.
We're going to have you do something that I think is
a really interesting application of machine learning.
It's identifying who was the author of a piece of text.
So for a little bit of background this actually came up in
the news a couple years ago.
J. K. Rowling had written a book under the pseudonym Robert Galbraith.
And there was some, some machine learning, some text forensic work that
was done, and they were able to figure out that even though it didn't say J.
K. Rowling on it, the writing style was distinctive enough, and the,
and the vocabulary usage was distinctive enough that they were able to
identify who wrote it anyway.
We'll be doing something like that in this in this project except we'll
be identifying the authors of emails.
So we have a bunch of emails from someone named Chris and
a bunch of emails from someone named Sara.
And the question is, using Naive Bayes, can you identify who is the author of,
of a new email, an unseen email?
So, let's get started.